so here's my promise to you guys today
I can show you how to get strangers to
want to buy your stuff
and I want to be clear the lead getting
strategies I share with you today
work for Real Estate medical Auto
homeowners insurance Health Care local
businesses home services financial
services consumer services software apps
e-learning online businesses e-commerce
and anything that sells stuff
to anyone
and I know they work because I use them
in our portfolio companies today which
include software local business
e-commerce consumer services medical
services Professional Services home
services and more
so I know this works from experience and
not Theory which brings up one of my
favorite quotes from LH Hardwick a man
with an experience is never at the mercy
of a man with an opinion
so that being said
let's begin
100 million dollar leads how to get
strangers to want to buy your stuff
so first things first for those of you
who do know me I want to address the
elephant in the room
is Alex going to finally sell us
something has anyone else been wondering
this
because it's been two years and the only
thing I've made available for purchase
is a Kindle book for a dollar and ninety
nine cents
so I can't tell you the answer to that
yet you'll have to stay and find out but
what I can tell you is at the end of the
presentation
we will be exporting the list of every
single person here alive
to give you the special project that
I've been working on for four years
and I can't tell you what it is yet
you'll find out in a moment but what I
can tell you is it's more than a gift
card it's less than a Tesla and every
single person here live today will get
one for free
and you will be the only people who get
one
and I did it this way so that next time
I say be there it'll be worth it
anyone not here will believe me because
I give them proof that I keep my
promises
and to the same degree as we dive in I
don't expect you to take my word for how
good the opportunity I'm about to share
with you is
I want to prove it to you
so let me explain
so when I see stuff like this it bothers
me right you see books this is how to
Market a book and you can look and say
you know there's 14 reviews on it so I
don't need to read the book to know that
the book doesn't contain contents that
know how to Market a book because I have
evidence in the real world that the
concepts the book are not effective
I don't need to read it I already know
it isn't good and it's kind of like
a dentist with bad teeth or somebody
claiming they can help you grow your
social media flying with less than 100
followers right you should walk the walk
if you're going to talk the talk in fact
I'd argue that the walk is the only talk
that matters
and so a lot of what I do is somewhat
meta meaning I'm trying to both Show and
Tell at the same time
so for example my first book 100 million
dollar offers answered the question what
do I sell
answer so good an offer is so good
people feel stupid saying no
it demonstrated the concept it outlined
creating a grand slam offer it was high
value
it included a free course with no opt-in
which today is over a million views
which was high value with a low price
relative to what it delivered
and a high price to Value discrepancy
100 million offers is itself a grand
slam offer using the value equation as
its guiding star
and two years later it's still number
one in every category it's listed with
over fifteen thousand five stars
it helps unless you go from 50 45 000 a
month to 170 000 a month it helps until
you go from ten thousand a month to
forty five thousand a month to help
Scott 10x his business from 50 to 100 a
month to 53 000 a month and Tanner get
his first business started and get to
five thousand a month from zero as a kid
in his twenties
and if you want the bigger numbers it
helps Antoine go from 50 000 a month to
750 000 a month
and the zillions of other real stories
who use the stuff in 100 million dollar
offers to start or grow their businesses
so I can feel confident saying its
success became its own proof its content
works
and so after releasing that book in July
of 2021
I wanted to use the next 24 months
leading up to this event as one thing
proof
proof that the stuff that I show in 100
million dollar leads actually works to
get leads today in the real world and
it'll work for you too
because I wasn't born with a five
million person audience this is only 24
months ago on YouTube
and this is today
and this was 24 months ago on my podcast
a completely different platform and this
is today
and I did this spending only two days
per month dedicated to advertising with
the rest of my time running our
portfolio
in fact during this time within the
first 24 months our portfolio companies
on average 2.8 x revenue and 4.7 next
profit
meaning you can still do the stuff that
grows your company without spending all
your time getting leads you just need to
do it better
and I wanted to use this event as my own
evidence for the book I used all eight
methods which I'll explain shortly to
advertise the book
I did it with the sole purpose to show
that they work to advertise anything to
any one period
so I used all the methods in the book to
advertise the book itself
because if you know what you're doing
you don't need a lot of time you just
need to do the right stuff the right way
but knowing what to do is the hardest
part
again which is why we've dedicated our
huge resources to this mission to make
real business education accessible for
everyone
and I'm going to do my darnest to live
up to that idea for you guys today that
is my promise
so I'm going to deliver to two types of
people today
type one
for people who need to put their oxygen
mask on and take care of themselves and
their family I promise you I will help
you get closer to that today for free
period so you're going to want to stay
until the end because I'm going to
deliver on that big time and I'm saying
until my absolute Last Breath believe me
when I say it we're going to be on a on
a twisty and Tourney Road today it'll be
fun
and for group two for those of you who
are in a position to help me pay it
forward I'm going to show you how it's
in your self-interest to help me help
everyone else and if you decide to join
me I'll show you how we can accomplish
both our missions together
because at the end of the day no one's
going to save you life is not a bedtime
story The Cavalry isn't coming you're it
so you've got to learn this stuff period
so now that we got that out of the way
let's get some leads
so let's Zoom all the way out
who here would like to start or grow
their business bigger than it currently
is let me know in the chat
great otherwise this would have been a
very short presentation
so rather than talk about all the ways
that we could grow it I want to take the
reverse approach
how could you guarantee that you'd
shrink or never grow to begin with
answer tell no one about your stuff
and if no one knows about your stuff we
can be pretty sure they aren't going to
buy it
we laugh but some of you are doing this
right now
so let's assume that you already have
something to sell amazing valuable thing
if more people find out about it do you
make more money yes
so here's a writer Downer all else being
equal when you double your leads you
double your business
sometimes it really is that simple
there's a reason these companies hit
billions almost overnight
they had already advertised enough to
build that size company they just needed
to make an offer
and that's great for them but what if
you're in the reverse situation you have
an offer and no one to give it to
then you need to let them know about
your stuff
in other words you need to advertise
bottom line advertising is important
because if no one knows about your stuff
no one buys it
but there's another huge reason getting
leads is so important for entrepreneurs
if you always know how to get more leads
it gives you endless chances to get it
right
and as much as I could keep hitting this
point I figured I might as well give you
a sneak peek of what's inside the book
so I'm going to read the first page to
you
is that all right you guys mind on that
all right
you have to sell stuff to make money it
seems simple enough but everyone tries
to skip to the make money part it
doesn't work I tried
you need all the pieces you need the
stuff to sell and offer you need people
to sell it to leads then you got to get
all those people to buy it sales
once you put all those in place then you
can make money
my first book 100 million dollar offers
covers the first step and gives you the
stuff it answers the age-old question
what should I sell
answer and offer so good people feel
stupid saying no
but strangers can only buy your stuff if
they know you exist this takes leads
leads mean a lot of different things to
a lot of different people but most agree
that they're the first step to getting
more customers in simpler terms it means
they've got the problem to solve and the
money to spend if you're reading this
book you already know that leads don't
magically appear you need to go get them
more precisely you need to need to help
them need to help them find you so they
can buy your stuff and the best part is
you don't have to wait you can force
them to find you
you do that through advertising
advertising the process of making known
lets strangers know about the stuff you
sell if more people know about the stuff
you sell then you sell more stuff if you
sell more stuff then you make more money
having lots of leads makes it hard to be
poor advertising lets you have a
terrible product and still make money it
lets you be terrible at sales and still
make money
it lets you make a ton of mistakes and
still make money
in short having this skill gives you
endless chances to get it right and in
the unforgiving world of business Second
Chances are hard to come by so you might
as well load up advertising is a skill
worth having and this book 100 million
dollar leads shows you exactly how to do
it
so
here's what I'm going to do in our short
time together
number one share a few breakthrough
experiences I had when learning how to
advertise to save my businesses you will
get my lesson without my scar
two give you guys a bunch of money
making stuff this one I can promise you
will
trust me
three invite you to join me on my
mission of making real business
education accessible for everyone and
four get out of your way so you can tear
off the wrapping paper and dig into my
last four years of work
cool
great
so here's a visual of our journey
together
let's start with the first way that you
get leads
warm Outreach
so here's how I learned it
so here I am a defense contractor top
secret clearance I'm 21 years old I'm
not happy my work I wanted to start a
business but I was too chicken
maybe some of you guys are in this boat
so I'd have started decided to start a
fitness non-profit because I liked
Fitness but I was still afraid to charge
money and if I failed at a non-profit
and still had my job it wouldn't hurt my
status right safe bet
but I wanted people who participated to
have some skin in the game so they'd
still care and try
I called it the free training project
this is my actual outside I was able to
find it
so the premise was simple people would
donate 500 to a thousand dollars to the
charity of their choice and I would
train them online for no compensation
and I'd give them nutrition workouts a
weekly weekly eating out guide and
answer questions in between
and that idea was all great except I had
no customers
so I reached out to every one of my
friends list 101 and I asked if they
knew anyone who'd be interested I was
like hey do you know anybody who's
looking to get in shape
and out of thousands of them
six
six said yes
so they donated I trained them and
months later they got results
I still have the first six to this day
eventually I wanted to make this a real
business but they were paying a charity
and not me so I asked them to start
paying me directly I was the charity now
and a few did
and that's how I advertised to start my
first business using warm Outreach AKA
reaching out to people who know you one
on one
and learning to advertise this way saved
me from a career I didn't enjoy and got
me started on my entrepreneurial Journey
you can look at the difference in my
facial expression between these two
pictures these are only a few months
apart you can see how much this meant to
me
so that's how I learned worm Outreach
here's how I used it for this book
the cool part about where mountain is no
matter how advanced you get you still
use it
for example I reached out to some of my
buddies privately and asked them to come
to my book launch event and they're here
with us now
and whether you're getting your first
five customers your next five customers
or you're launching a new product in a
division of a company it often starts
the same way with warm Outreach and the
best part is you can start using it the
moment you get off this presentation
today
so that's how I learned it here's how I
used it for this book oh sorry here's
how you use for the book here's where
you can use it today so warm Outreach
works on email phone call direct
messages physical mail voicemails
carrier pigeons anything where you talk
to people one-on-one all right on
platforms like these
so that's where you can use it today now
let's talk about the second way to get
leads posting free content so here's how
I learned it
now after I had some customers I wanted
more
but I didn't know how because I had
already messaged my entire contact list
so I made a post
so here was my first ever public
advertisement
you can see it April 9 2013 Baltimore
Maryland which is where I'm from
everyone for those of you who know me
you know two things one I am terrible
with all things technological for
example I just heard about Spotify a few
weeks ago seriously two I love training
nutrition and fitness more than well a
whole lot so today is sort of special
because it marks a day where my love of
training vanquished see me being fancy
here vanquished my fear of Technology
what do I mean for the better part of a
year I've been taking part in a free
personal training project with the idea
that I would give away free personal
training to anyone who is willing to
give some of their 500 to a thousand
dollars to a cause of their choice
this way they wouldn't have to be
motivated by the same thing as me but be
motivated to give to their cause and
benefit themselves when I first
introduced the idea I was happily
surprised with the amount of positive
support I received so almost a year for
my first client I now have a website to
formally show you some of the
Transformations that have gone underway
using my programming and as a formal
means of contacting me about signing up
I currently have a few slots open my
roster so drop me a quick note if you're
interested thanks so much take a quick
second to check out the ridiculous
transformations
and unlike before
I now had some proof I could advertise
so I started making posts about what I
was doing with my clients with some
Fitness content in between so on the
left you can see some of the fitness
content and on the right you can see
some of the testimonials and from that
content in those testimonials over the
next month I messaged anyone who
interacted with any post I had and asked
them if they wanted help and that gave
birth to the body forward skinny to soil
project you can see the date there
and I signed up 20 guys at 200 bucks a
month which equated at four thousand
dollars a month learning how to
advertise through making content allowed
me to eat in the early days between my
job and before I started my first gym
learning to get leads through posting
saved me from a life I didn't want it
gave me the resources that I needed to
learn more
now what I didn't know is that I had
unknowingly stumbled on the second way
you can advertise posting content AKA
you post content to people who know you
one to many
so that's how I learned it here's how I
use it for this book
so we recorded content months prior to
the launch and planned it out and this
was our actual calendar so you can see I
had 17 shorts filmed I had six long
forms filmed we had 143 total posts 20
sorry 143 total lead post 2200 total
posts and that was across Instagram
LinkedIn Twitter Tick Tock YouTube
shorts and threads all right and I want
to pause here because I think it's an
important lesson that it took me too
long to figure out which is that if you
do have an audience or you do start
posting content if you do want to start
promoting something
you don't want to just stop posting the
stuff that your entire audience is there
for and then only start talking about
your thing you keep talking about your
thing as much as you were before and
then start your promotions on top of
that which means you actually need to do
even more during that period of time if
you want to promote something and I
think this is one of the big mistakes
that a lot of people make when they are
trying to promote something to an
audience
and so combining the leads post with the
content post this is over 300 pieces per
week
and here are the resulting Impressions
from those posts
over 400 million impressions
and we use the same content framework in
every post to maximize the likelihood
that we hook retain and reward people
for clicking consuming and coming back
that is the hook retain reward framework
you'll see it again
and that resulted in 194
000 registrations
so almost half of you guys here today
and here's the craziest thing if you
were to pay for those cpms
at 20 bucks each
that's three million dollars a month in
free advertising that's how powerful
this is
so
that's how I used it for this book
here's how you can use it today
so the fact that I got my first
customers from organic content then and
built the following that we have now is
why I can tell you that it worked then
and it works now
and although the platforms may change
the principles remain the same
and like anything you can scale this
from one post a week to 250 posts a week
so you can do this in tiny amounts or
huge amounts it works the same
and here are some examples of platforms
available to do this on today you got
YouTube Shorts YouTube Longs podcasts
SiriusXM Radio LinkedIn tick tock
Instagram stories Instagram reels
Instagram posts Twitter and more
so let's talk about the third way to get
leads
running paid ads
so here's how I learned it
now back to our story
once I had clients from posting content
I wanted more noticing a recurring theme
Here
so I started shadowing at a gym the gym
owner Sam didn't use any paid
advertising he used a method called
Groupon to get new customers some of you
younger Lads might not remember this but
some of the older folks in the room will
after watching how it worked I was
convinced I could do the same thing and
launch my own gym
so right before I left this gym to start
my own I remember calling a mentor I
said okay so here's how it works you get
a hundred people who buy your Groupon
every month for 39 bucks and from there
you get 40 of them to stay for 150 bucks
a month so you get paid to get new
customers and every month you add
another 6 000 per month in recurring
Revenue he was like I'm not sure it's
going to be that easy but you have my
blessing so
I went out signed my first lease and
started my Groupon but
nothing happened
crickets
so here I am freaking out that I just
signed my life away with no way to get
leads and here's the part of the story
that many of my audience don't know
so I was actually supposed to have a
partner at my first location and two
weeks before our location was supposed
to open he said hey we should go to this
marketing seminar cost three grand they
guarantee that if you don't make 10
grand by the end of the weekend they'll
give your money back and despite being
quite broke I obviously said I could use
10 grand let's go
and so over those two days I didn't make
10 grand but I did learn about this
thing called Facebook ads
then when I got back from that Workshop
something unexpected happened
we broke up
my partner backed out of the partnership
so I had to use the rest of my savings
to pay his half to open the gym
so here I am sleeping on the floor with
no clients I owe rent in weeks I have
one month saved up so I put up the
ugliest ad you've ever seen just like
I'd learned at the workshop I'm looking
for five local residents to take place
in a free six-week challenge you must
let us use your performing after
pictures in our Marketing in exchange
for the program click the link to sign
up no images no videos no frills just
words all caps
and it worked
I signed up 29 members before I opened
in the city I knew no one I actually
ended up sending this picture to my
father
to show them that I was doing something
good
and funny enough the cash I collected
from them was exactly enough to pay my
rent
I still remember the business account
going to zero at the end of the month
woof
but the next month I spent more money on
ads and got more customers and then more
and learning how to run ads allowed me
to start my gym in Huntington Beach on
my own without a partner without savings
without knowing anyone
and if I had not learned how to run paid
ads on a random weekend I would not be
standing in front of you today
truly if I hadn't learned how to get
leads my gym would have gone under in
less than a month because I only had a
month saved up
and I would have had to go back to this
job as a failure and that would have
sucked
simply put learning to run paid ads gave
me the ability to survive long enough to
figure out what I was doing
and just like that I had learned the
third way that you can let other people
know about your stuff
paid ads AKA letting strangers know
one to many
so that's how I learned them here's how
I used it for this book so for this book
launch we ran paid ads
on these platforms YouTube Shorts
YouTube songs Facebook Instagram reels
Instagram stories Instagram posts and
tick tock
and I followed the exact steps in this
book so that you could all go back and
look at them as examples to model
I wrote These simple ads
using this simple three-step framework
from the book The what who when
framework I go into very deep
description of every aspect of how you
can script A Nat and how you get endless
variations with one framework
and then these ads got these results we
spent 275 000 we got 137 000 of you here
and our cost per lead is about two bucks
and I pushed them to this simple landing
page which I got directly from the book
this is layout number two
and it had a 55 opt-in rate for those
who know what that is
are you guys seeing how we use the stuff
in the book to advertise the book itself
you guys getting that getting some hands
on the screens you guys getting that all
right
AKA proof that this stuff works
so that's how I use it for this book
here's how you can use it today
you can use it on all these platforms
Hulu radio LinkedIn Tick Tock Spotify
Instagram Twitter podcast and more and
the best part is if you know what you're
doing you can immediately start using
paid ads to get leads for your business
today
they're the fastest way to get more
leads especially if you're like I was
with no one knowing you like I was in
Hudson Beach when I started right and
they work even if you have no following
and you can start with as little as a
few dollars a day
and you can scale them as much as you
want for example today across our
portfolio we spend more than a million
dollars per week in ads
and a lot of people try and make it
sound complicated
they're not they only make them sound
complicated because they understand them
well enough yet to explain them simply I
must say that again
people only make ads sound complicated
because they don't understand them well
enough to make them simple
because once you do understand them
they're easier than you think so that's
pretty much what I did for a while I
kept posting content I kept reaching out
to folks and running paid ads and that's
how I scaled my gyms
and was able to eventually sell my
locations
and that's when I started my next
company gym launch our licensing
business when everything went really
right
for context over the next four years we
took out 40 million dollars in owner
distributions
and then
something terrible happened and it went
really wrong really fast
and so I was forced to get a new way to
get leads
which brings us to the fourth way to get
leads
cold Outreach
so here's how I learned it
so whoosh it's 20 20. and I uh hit
puberty again
and now I've scaled and sold my gyms I'm
now scaling gym launcher gym licensing
company using all the methods that I've
discussed so far
but all of a sudden covet hits
and 100 of my customers aren't allowed
to do business
so here's what happened
month one fifteen percent of gyms
permanently close
by month six another 15 percent of gyms
meaning 30 percent of all gyms are
forever out of business
with the rest seriously struggling
my clients are scared my employees are
scared my ads are failing and somehow I
have to figure out a way to get more
customers and I'm not really sure what
to do
so one morning I wake up early and check
my Instagram and I see a new message it
says hey Alex kill told me you guys
don't need salesman anymore so my offer
got pulled I quit my job to accept it
I'm super honored as you consider me I
hope you consider me again next time you
have openings
I scrolled up in the conversation
I was the one who had told him to apply
I felt horrible so I messaged him I was
like you on and he was so he hopped on a
call
here's how the conversation went so he
said he worked at a gym software company
doing 10 million a month I was like holy
cannoli
I was like okay well uh how do you guys
get clients he's like oh we're 100
outbound
I was like huh so then I asked him what
was that offer that kale pulled
he's like oh it's going to be a closer I
was like huh
well you think you could do that
outbound stuff here he's like yeah I
could do it I'm confident I can make it
profitable in 90 days so I said deal
I'll front you the time of the money to
spin this up and so I hired him and we
built an outbound machine together
and so here's what happened over the
next few months September the first
month zero sales zippola nothing
October two sales
December for sales January six sales
February 10 sales March 14 sales April
20 sales May 30 sales and 480 000 in
monthly Revenue
cold Outreach save gym launch during its
hardest time during covid
and it was pivotal in making it a
sellable company that didn't rely on my
face and keep growing
to this day the company is up 45 from
what I sold without bound equating to
over 50 of sales
learning to advertise with cold outbound
kept my company alive
and that's how I learned cold Outreach
which is simply privately letting people
know who don't know you about your stuff
AKA advertising one to one to strangers
so that's how I learned it here's how I
used it for this book
so I reached out to people to ask to be
on their podcast to speak about the book
I was like are you going to build your
podcast they're like you sure can
and this is actually a more advanced
move combining two types of advertising
which I'll get to later
but if you see a boatload of podcasts
come out after the book is out that's
where many of them came from
so that's how I use it for the book
here's how you can use it today
you can knock on 100 Doors you can send
100 DMS you can make 100 calls you can
leave 100 voicemails all you got to do
is get away to contact them figure out
what to say contact them until they're
ready and able to listen that's it
and you can do it on all these platforms
SMS DMS emails LinkedIn messenger
Instagram messenger Twitter messenger
voicemail physical mail and of course
carrier pigeons
and you can start with a tiny budget all
you need is time a way to contact people
and knowing what to say when they reply
that's all you need
and you can scale all the way up using
other people's time and automation
and the best part is you get to pick who
you reach out to you pick your own leads
so you can make sure that you only reach
out to the most qualified Perfect Fit
highest value targets
for example if you only want to reach
out to hedge fund managers over a
billion dollars in assets under
management you can do that for context
within our portfolio we do a total of 15
000 plus reach outs per day
and generate zillions that's the actual
number zillions of engaged leads per day
as a result
as a fun proof Point Jim launch has
spoken to not reached out to spoken to
000 gym owners
so I'm being clear they've gotten on the
phone with
000 gym owners in an industry of only
150 000 gyms in health clubs all right
that's one out of six of all gyms
and that's how you can know this stuff
works
so now you know the four methods of
advertising which I call the core four
they're the only four ways you can let
other people know about your stuff
core four number one warm Outreach core
for number two posting free content cool
for number three running paid ads call
for number four cold Outreach
but the natural question is
are there other ways to advertise
and the answer is yes and no
you on your own cannot advertise in
other ways
but other people can for you
and I called those people the four lead
getters
you've got customers employees agencies
and Affiliates
and Lead Getters using the core4
complete the advertising cycle
for example let's say you post free
content to tell people about your stuff
and get customers who then tell other
people about your stuff using warm
Outreach and you get more customers
or
let's say you run paid ads to tell
people about your stuff and get
Affiliates who then tell other people
about your stuff by posting free content
to their audiences and you get more
customers
and so the most efficient way to
advertise is to let other people do it
on your behalf because only two people
can let strangers know about the stuff
you sell you and other people and there
are more of them than there are of you
and I can explain the insane power of
lead Getters with one simple comparison
on one hand you can do the core four all
day every day to get leads
your work is high
your leads are low
your Leverage is lowest
on the other hand you can get one person
to get an army of lead getters
to do the core four for you
so your work is now low
your leads are high and your Leverage is
highest
in other words in the second scenario
you work way less but you get four times
the leads
and that's the insane power of lead
Getters and once you know how to harness
them you can get as many leads as you
darn well please without spending your
time on it it's how our portfolio
generates twenty thousand plus leads per
day
without me doing any advertising for
them to get leads to be clear I
advertise to get portfolio companies but
I don't advertise for my portfolio
companies to get customers
and that's leverage the difference
between what you put in and what you get
out
and that's how you build a 100 million
dollar leads machine
the same one that got five hundred
thousand plus of you amazing individuals
here today
and I don't have time to get to explain
the other four lead Getters in detail
but let me at least give you the gist
you don't do lead Getters you do the
core four to get them and then they do
the core four on your behalf
so let me give you a couple examples
so first and simplest you have customers
who then get you other customers it's
how my last book sold 467 000 copies
with zero dollars in paid ads
so real quick who you heard about this
event from someone else or because you
read the last book drop a thumb in the
chat
give me some thumbs who here came for
that came because of that reason
Bernie did Nicholas did Javier did
William did Charles did Nicholas another
Nicholas Suzanne all right
great this referral stuff works
then you've got employees who do the
core four on your behalf which is how
Mosey media our team made the 143 book
posts of content and 2200 plus pieces in
the last six weeks
so real quick how many of you guys saw
content about this event drop a thumb in
the chat
who here came from content rather than
because you read the last book or
someone told you to
great
Tyron Jacob
this team stuff works
then you've got agencies who post
content run ads or do Outreach on your
behalf
that's who actually click the button
since we don't actually run ads for our
holding company we're a holding company
we don't actually transact and so we had
an agency run the ads on our behalf so
real quick who here heard about this
event from Paid ads that you saw paid
ads is that what made you click and come
in Click a thumb or drop a thumb in the
chat
Santiago Marguerite Jawad all right
Vaughn there we go
great that's how you can know that this
stuff works today
so then you've got Affiliates who do the
core forward of Their audience on your
behalf which is how we had 23
722 Affiliates post content run ads and
email their lists about this event
real quick who here heard about this
event from another business drop a thumb
in the chat
Greg
arika Raphael Lauren Robbie Mona
so for the many of you who are here
because someone else referred you from
another business thank you
over a hundred and four thousand three
hundred and sixty one of you are here
from affiliates
and that's how you know this affiliate
stuff works
and the result of using the core four
and the four lead Getters is
proof
everyone here today
and that's how you know this stuff works
and it'll work for you
okay so far in this presentation we
covered you make more money when more
people find out about your stuff when
you double your leads you double your
business there are only two types of
people who can get you leads you and
other people we talked about the core
four
why these companies hit billions
overnight AKA advertising we talked
about warm reach outs we talked about
posting content we talked about the hook
retain reward framework we talked about
how I use paid ads for this book we
talked about the best landing page
templates
we talked about how I learned cold
Outreach we talked about how to get
leverage with lead Getters talk to how I
use customer referrals to get even more
leads
and how we used our team to get even
more leads and how we used advertising
agencies to get even more leads and how
we used Affiliates to get even more
leads
and that's how you know this stuff works
and it'll work for you after all
warm Outreach work to get my first
customers posting content work to make
enough for me to quit my job
paid ads work to keep my gym from
failing before even
began and even eventually grew
cold Outreach worked to save gym launch
during covid and made it a sellable
business
referrals work to explode 100 million
dollar offers employees work to make the
content to remote this event agency work
to run the ads for this event
and 23 722 Affiliates work to advertise
this book event to get a hundred and
four thousand three hundred and sixty
one of you here
can you see how knowing how to get leads
can give you the freedom to pursue the
business or life you want
can you see how learning to use these
eight advertising methods can 2x 5x 100x
your business
can you see how learning how to get
leads on demand gives you endless
chances to figure it out
in short can you see why advertising AK
knowing how to get leads is a skill
worth having
and this skill may just be the bridge
between where you are and wherever you
want to go it has been for me
great
so here's what I know
even if we had a full day together
instead of just 90 minutes it's gonna be
hard almost impossible for me to give
you all that I could give you
no matter how good anyone is one 90
minute presentation isn't going to
change your life you need more than that
and while everything I've given you
today is valuable it's just the tip of
the iceberg and if you like what I've
shared with you so far you'll love what
I have for you next
you see before today
I was faced with one of two choices
the first option was to part ways with
you and then just hope that you on your
own would figure it out
my second option was I could take a more
active role in responsibility for your
success and create a win-win situation
I chose the second option
the result of working six hours a day
for two years
everything I know about generating 100
million plus a year in sales
everything I know about getting leads
from a decade of advertising
and so it's with great pleasure to
introduce you to the 100 million dollar
lead system
with this system you will wield all
eight methods as a master of advertising
getting leads on command at prices your
competition would drool over
so here's what you guys are gonna get
this is about to get bananas so just
buckle up that's my warning that's my
disclaimer before we rock and roll here
if you're someone who doesn't get enough
replies or opt-ins or your web pages
don't convert or people don't trust you
enough to buy or your religious play
don't cost too much then pay attention
this is for you
lead magnet mastery all right now you
might be wondering what's a lead magnet
a lead man is a complete solution to a
narrow problem it's the free thing
giveaway before you're paid things you
can get more people to buy
here's how it'll make you money let's
say you sell widgets all right if you go
up to 100 people on the street and say
hey buy my widget maybe one of them will
buy everyone else will say pound sand I
don't know who you are I don't trust you
now let's introduce a lead magnet before
your core offer so you go up to the same
hundred people and say hey can I give
you some value for free can I solve this
problem for you for free a greater
percentage of those people say yeah you
can solve that problem for me and now
with that bigger pool of people that you
have now gained trust and solve the
problem for you say hey I solved that
first problem but now you've got the
second problem
let me solve that for you in exchange
for money and then more than one of
those people will say yes
making a lead magnet the right way can
2x 5x sometimes 10x the leads that you
have while adding value to the
marketplace this is a big part I think
people miss about lead magnets is that
of course when you have the right lead
magnet you make way more sales but what
people Miss is that you actually also
provide Goodwill to the marketplace
because 99 of people are never going to
buy from you and that's okay that's how
it works but they are the ones who will
build your reputation
and so if you provide free value to the
marketplace you build your reputation
while also making more sales and that's
the secret power of lead magnets now to
show how powerful this is I personally
took on a group of 10 businesses on my
software Allen to implement the lead
magnet system
they were in Chiropractic online fitness
Dental Physical Therapy in-home services
in real estate and even flow tanks
and here are their actual numbers from
implementing the system all right so you
can see one through ten you can see at
the bottom we had some stragglers with
some people who didn't do very much and
you can see at the top we had some
people who did a lot
each company who fully adopted the new
lead man exploded in revenue and growth
in fact in the first 90 days each
business went through went from zero to
six thousand a month in additional
Revenue to month two 19 000 a month in
additional Revenue to month three thirty
four thousand dollars a month in
additional Revenue
so the average business went up by month
three to thirty four thousand nine
hundred seventy two dollars
on average and that included the folks
that did nothing
so you could say this worked
and so here's what lead magnet Masters
show you how to do step one figure out
the best problem to solve all right this
is probably one of the biggest mistakes
people make when they're when they're
picking lead matches actually solving
the wrong problem there are problems you
solve that get people to buy and they're
problem solved that waste your time you
got to pick the right ones second figure
out how to solve it third figure out how
to deliver it fourth test what to name
it
because if they don't like what you name
it they're never going to consume it to
begin with which brings it to number
five which is make it easy to consume
because they don't consume it they're
not going to get value if they don't
give value they're not going to buy
step six make it darn good there's a
specific way that I approach lead Max
that make them better and make their
increase their perception of value that
can dramatically change the buy rates
afterwards
and finally step seven make it easy for
them to tell you they want more
this sounds crazy but step seven is
actually the number one thing that
people miss when they are making lead
magnets and why they give a lead magnet
away and then no one buys
in fact this system alone permanently 17
extra applications at acquisition.com in
three months so this is 2022 so I
already still had a lot of traffic we
had a relatively big audience even last
year and this was when you introduced a
new lead man using this and I was
already doing Millions a month before
discovering this new way that 17x my
Elites all right so for you do you think
you can at least double your lead flow
overnight
probably for me the system cost me
twenty three thousand seven hundred and
twelve dollars in development and three
months of tests to figure out the hard
slow and expensive way
but I want to save you the three months
of trial and error and the twenty three
thousand seven hundred and twelve
dollars it took me to learn this and
just give you the fast Jeep and easy way
is that cool
this is so valuable you can literally do
nothing else I show you just use lead
magnet Mastery and double your leads
tomorrow
which I value today at only a fraction
of my investment of time money at 997
dollars
so that's the first thing you're going
to get
now oh I've got more
if you haven't started your business yet
or you want to start a side hustle or
you're about to launch a new project or
you have less than 20 customers then pay
attention I made this for you
the first five clients framework
here's how it'll make you money let's
say you want to get leads for a new
thing on a zero dollar budget you're
going to want a way to advertise that's
reliable low risk repeatable and low
cost
and warm Outreach is a single
advertising method that best meets these
requirements so if you need to get
customers this is the fastest cheapest
and most certain way to get them
and using room Outreach the right way
we'll get you the first five customers
that you need to start the business quit
the job or launch the new product in
fact Alexis used the principles from
first five clients from to start her
first online business and got her first
three customers in her first month
and then got three more customers the
next month and then got three more
customers the next month
and then she used some of the more
advanced stuff that I'm going to show
you in a second
and went from three customers per month
to three customers a week
and the best part is the first five
clients from X Works no matter what you
sell
so here's what I'll show you how to do
step one get your list
step two pick the right platform step
three personalize your message step four
reach out so I'll give you the exact
scripts the exact openers the things
that we do the ACA framework that we've
used to massage customers and Prospects
to get them to want to buy
step six get them to invite their
friends
step seven how to make the easiest offer
in the world this is the one that
everyone wants to say yes to and
especially if you're starting out I'll
just give it to you that way people say
yes to you on the first shot step eight
how to get the most from your leads
which is there's three ways you can
monetize leads I'll show you all three
nine how how much and when to start
charging especially when you're starting
out getting the right price and knowing
when to start charging someone and how
much is one of the most confusing parts
I'll show you step-by-step process that
works every time
in Step 10 I'll show you how to keep
your list warm so it keeps bringing you
leads month after month after month
this is step by step the exact system
that I used to get my first clients for
free all right this system cost me two
years of working a job I didn't love and
two years of lost income to figure out
the not fun way so that's a picture of
me 10 years ago
but I want to save you the two years it
took me to figure it out and just give
you the shortcut aka the fun way you can
so you can start tomorrow
and for many of you here today this is
the only thing you need to quit your job
and start that business that you have
been thinking about
and even though quitting your job and
pursuing your dream is priceless
to make sure you can actually get
started I value the first five clients
from I can only fraction of my
investment time money at 297 dollars
so here's what you get you get a lead
magnet Mastery so you can get way more
leads than you currently are you can get
the first five clients Frameworks you
can get your first five clients for free
total value 12.94
. now I want to talk to somebody else in
the audience
if you're someone who wants to build a
personal brand
or you want to add boatloads of free
media to your business or build a warm
audience then I made this for you
the MOSI media content method for the
first time ever we're opening up the
kimono of what we actually did to build
this brand
and so here's how posting content the
right way makes you money
one it will grow your audience as a
natural consequence when you grow your
audience you get more buyers and here's
the third one that people don't expect
is that when you do this all other lead
methods benefit so let me explain so
let's say you use warm Outreach or paid
ads to get customers well if someone
clicks on an ad
a lot of us don't actually immediately
buy you click on an ad and then you
click the profile you consume some
content you see if someone's legit and
then you go back and buy
and so if you have content there done
the right way you'll actually lift all
other lead generation methods you'll get
way more leads for less money and this
is in addition to the people that
actually come in from the content itself
for many of you can cut your lead cost
in half while also growing your sales
and so here's what the most immediate
content method will show you how to do
number one hook attention get them to
notice your content so I'll show you how
we pick great topics there's five
buckets that I use every time that are
completely unique to the individual so
you never have to look like another
Mickey Mouse copy paste person ever
again
B we did a we looked at a 50-year
meta-analysis of news headlines the most
viral news headlines that got shared the
most and rather than give you a formula
there are seven Timeless themes that
humans respond to and I'll show you how
to put those themes into your headlines
without having to follow some you know
cookie cutter format
which brings me to C how to structure
the content to get shared sometimes you
have the same content formatted
differently and then boom it gets a
hundred times the views are reach
but once they notice your content you
got to get them to consume it so you
have to retain the attention so I'll
show you how to use lists steps and
stories to keep people watching
and then finally reward attention which
is satisfy the reason they consumed it
to begin with all right how do you keep
promises elegantly and this is the
important part at the right times a lot
of people keep promises too early or
don't do it at all or keep the wrong
promise and if you do it the right way
you get a massive lift in the amount of
people who share it
this is the exact system that I used to
get from here to here and get almost
half of everyone here today
and it took me two years to figure it
out
and a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
a month in payroll but I'm not going to
ask you for two years of your life and
3.6 million dollars I'm just going to
hand you the keys
this is literally what Built My Brand my
most valuable asset in 24 months
and it can help you build one too which
I value today at a thousandth of my
investment in time and money at one
thousand nine hundred ninety seven
dollars so here's what you get number
one is I'll show you how to cut your
lead cost in half using lead magnet
Mastery number two you're gonna get your
first five clients so you can pick
whatever platform you want to get
customers on you're going to get the
most immediate content method so you can
build the brand that you want to have
authority in whatever space you're in
total value 3291
now let's say you're in the opposite
situation you never want to be the face
you hate being on camera or making
content or you hate the constantly
changing platform algorithms but you
still want to make consistent sales
that I made this for you
the cold Outreach Playbook
so here's what code Outreach is also
number one you don't need to be good on
camera number two you don't need to make
tons of content number three your
competition will never know what you're
doing so you can operate in secrecy I
told you earlier there's a 10 million a
month business in Myspace I don't even
know they existed because they used
outbound
four if you do enough volume it becomes
incredibly reliable in short once you
have it going you become very hard to
stop
I already told you this Playbook has
been worth millions to me
getting this advertising method going
can 5x the value of your business and
now I use it across our portfolio to
instantly and reliably grow their sales
and value
and at the very least once you implement
it you can sleep well at night knowing
you'll always have leads
in fact Miguel used the principles from
cold Outreach playbook for his local
business he needed to get new customers
so you add it in outbound and within 90
days he had his first hundred thousand
dollar a month all right check out his
Revenue growth from cold Outreach so
month one he was just doing his normal
business and then boom he added in the
color Outreach Playbook and doubled his
business and then the next month he
maintained his Revenue thereafter
and you can see his comment there
and so here's what cold hours play we'll
show you how to do step one get a way to
contact them get your leads so I'll show
you how to buy lists how to scrape lists
using software and how to manually
assemble this if you're dead broke
step two I'll show you how to know what
to say all right so the exact voicemail
scripts that we use the exact email
scripts that we use the exact follow-up
scripts that we use the exact DM scripts
that we use and the warm-up Scripts
so how to personalize the messages at
scale to get replies and what to say
when they reply and how to convince
strangers to take the next step
and then finally step three contact them
when they're ready and able to listen so
I'll show you how we automate delivery
and automate distribution so that you
can get way more replies for Less effort
and the perfect follow-up sequence I
told you 15 000 reach outs a day we know
what the Cadence is I'll tell you it
works best
in fact this is the exact step-by-step
process that we scaled during covid as a
gym company so think about how
ridiculous this is
that was the sales growth we had during
covid as a gym company that's how
reliable this is once you get it going
and it was the largest contributor to
our 46.2 million dollar exit during
covid so if it was the missing link for
us then it can certainly work for you
now no matter what your economic
condition is around you and for me the
system cost me 150 000 in payroll in six
months of tests to figure out the
painful way
but I want to save you the six months of
trial and error and the 150 000 it took
me to learn this and just give you the
winning lottery numbers you just got to
cash them in
you could literally ignore everything
else I taught you today and use this to
figure out the one message you need to
send to make money and never worry about
where you get your next sale from again
that's it
which would be life-changing for you but
I value it today at a fraction of my
investment time money at one thousand
nine hundred ninety seven dollars so
you're gonna lead magnet Mastery so you
can make banging lead magnets that
people want to buy from you after you
can get the first five clients
Frameworks so that you can get your
first five clients for free even if you
have no dollars right now
the most media content method that will
help you build a brand that other people
want to pay you money to get in front of
your audience for that you can either
choose not to or you can sell them stuff
on your own
the cold Outreach playbook for people
who don't want to be on camera but still
make money
total value 52.88
now let's say you're the type person who
wants to get leads fast
Ricky Bobby style and have a higher risk
tolerance and when I'm on a smaller team
as you scale
then you're going to love this
the paid ads Playbook here's why they're
awesome they're the closest thing to
legally printing money they always work
it's just a matter of how well
you don't need to spend more time to get
more reach you just crank the spend
you don't need an audience or a
reputation you can test this with tiny
budgets and you can scale them with the
fused Revenue fewest humans per dollar
Revenue
and they're way way simpler than people
make them out to be and despite my
organic reputation I made my fortune
running ads
so believe me when I understand when I
say that I understand where you're at if
you don't have the life you want this is
my bank account on December 20th of
2016. this is not that long ago
and then I cracked paid ads
and 24 months later this was my income
after I expensed everything I can
imagine
cracking paid ads can be among the
fastest changes in wealth you ever
experience if you get it right it can
100x your business
for me at 20 000 X to my bank account is
probably because it was so low
so I feel qualified to speak on the top
and give you the secrets that most
people don't teach
so here's what paid ads Playbook will
show you how to do
number one know where to advertise 99 of
the time people are just starting the
wrong place
number two get the Right audience to see
it I can promise you if you get the
right person to see your ads your ads
don't even have to be that good
number three make the best ad for them
to see and the nice thing is that humans
have not changed so you can follow the
exact same process over and over again
step four get permission to contact them
because at the end of the day if they
don't give you permission
there's nothing you can do from there
and this is the exact system I use to
script every ad you saw over the past
six weeks which I followed to a t to
demonstrate that it works here are the
actual results from only one platform so
you can see here it's about two bucks a
lead just to give you some context
people who run events like this
generally pay between 10 and 50 dollars
per lead
this is way less
and across all platforms paid ads
brought in 137 000 of you today
and in case you're curious these ads
converted the same prices to cold
audiences
so with this you'll be able to get way
more better cheaper leads faster more
reliably period
so here's the deal it took me half a
decade to learn how to do this and
another half a decade to perfect the
system and that was hard
but I want to save you the losing
everything twice stage in the five years
of sucking for those of you know my
story and just give the cheat codes to
get it right the first time
you can skip every other Playbook and
get one profitable paid ads campaign
printing money and cover the investment
for this entire system for the rest of
your life all right which could create
generational wealth for you but I value
today at only fraction my investment at
1 997 so you can get lead magnet Mastery
so you can immediately get more leads
from whatever platforms you're on you
get the first five client framework
you're gonna get the most immediate
content method everything that we do
opening up the kimono to show you how to
scale your business
the cold Outreach Playbook so that you
can get leads bulletproof as long as you
have a phone as long as you have an
internet connection you can get
customers
the paid ads Playbook which scales
faster than any other way to get
customers total value 72.85
now let's say you're the type of person
who loves building great products or
wants to build somebody that lasts
generations and love taking care of
customers and prefer to go with the
highest profit margins possible then I
get it which is why I made this for you
the referral Playbook so what's a
referral you might ask a referral
happens when somebody a referrer sends
an Engaged lead to your business anyone
can refer but the best referrals come
from your customers so here's how it'll
make you money referrals are both worse
worth more and cost less which is a
dangerous combo for making money as a
business
and here's why this matters imagine you
have a four to one return on Advertising
that means for every one dollar you put
in you get four dollars back
and then you use the referral Playbook
and get every customer to refer one more
customer so you go from four to one to
eight to one but in reality those four
would then get you another four into
infinity and this is how you make crazy
profits
but at the end of the day to grow
forever you just got to get more
customers to refer than exit that's it
and once you do that you can grow as big
as you want
in fact this referral Playbook generated
300 000 a week in sales for us to gym
launch the best part is we found out by
accident when my ads got shut off for
two weeks and we still kept making sales
but after realizing it happened by
accident we reverse engineered what we
had done and started doing it on purpose
I spent the next six months interviewing
all the best businesses in our Network
and I took pages of notes then
re-categorized them by topic and then
look for common factors that they all
had and there were six and then we
started implementing them in our
locations and like clockwork we could
triple how many people stayed and how
many people they sent
and here's what the referral Playbook
will show you how to do step one figure
out your referral percentage to churn
percentage all right that is the ratio
that we will optimize for for the rest
of this
step two get more people to refer
without asking them all right this is
the result of those findings all right
so I'll show you how to pick better
customers how to set better expectations
how to get more people better results
how to get them faster results with just
two aspects one is actually getting
faster results the other is increasing
their perception of speed you can do
both
how to keep making your stuff better
and how to tell them what to buy next
because if they don't know what to buy
next you can be darn sure they're not
going to do it
in step three get more people to refer
by asking well all right and so what I'm
going to give you is my seven all-time
best referral programs that you can
Implement to get leads tomorrow all
right you can just copy and paste them
in fact Vadim copy and pasted one of my
referral programs into his business and
got 105 people and added 28 000 to his
annual revenue for free because that's
the beautiful thing about referrals it
costs nothing
while donating 2500 to Toys for Tots and
serving his community which is my
favorite way to do business do good and
make good money hand in hand
and this stuff works when you're
starting out
or when you're scaled all the way up
and rather than ask you through the
hundreds of interviews and Consulting
process I just want to give you the
answers to the test all right you could
literally do nothing else I showed you
today run one of my seven referral
programs in this Playbook and get
customers tomorrow all right which on
its own would cover the investment from
this entire program
which would be life-changing for you but
I value today only a fraction of my
investment of time money at 997 dollars
so here's what you get you get lead
magnet Mastery you get the first five
clients framework you get multimedia
content method you get the cold Outreach
Playbook you get the paid ads Playbook
you get the referral Playbook
total value 8282
now if you're the type of person who
loves building relationships
and you believe in expanding the size of
the pie and finding win-win scenarios
and want to create long-term allies on
your entrepreneurial Journey then you're
going to love this the affiliate
Playbook
so what's an affiliate an affiliate is a
lead getter they are an independent
business that tells Their audience to
buy your stuff Affiliates seem like
referrals on the outside but are much
different under the hood first they have
their own businesses and do their own
advertising second they agree to offer
your stuff to get to their engaged leads
in exchange for money free stuff or both
and so here's how Affiliates make you
more money so consider these two
scenarios scenario one you sell 10
customers per month worth ten thousand
dollars each
your business grows to a hundred
thousand dollars per month now mind you
you can change the zeros all right it
doesn't really matter but the concept
Remains the Same all right assuming no
other advertising or business plateaus
in 12 months you've made 1.2 million
dollars your Leverage is low again this
could be twelve hundred dollars twelve
thousand dollars 1.2 million or 120
million it doesn't matter but the
leverage of how you built it Still
Remains low because you're the one
getting customers
now let's look at scenario two
you sell 10 Affiliates per month not
customers you sell 10 Affiliates per
month and then each affiliate sells you
one new customer per month for you
and so every month you add another
hundred thousand dollars of Revenue on
top of last month
so it looks like this the first month
you get 10 Affiliates to send you 10
customers
the next month you get another 10
Affiliates who send you another 10
customers for a total of 20 new
customers
the next month another 10 Affiliates for
children of 30 sending you 30 customers
and Affiliates keep sending you
customers and you keep growing in 12
months you've made 7.8 million dollars
and it continues thereafter
the key point is that in both scenarios
you sell 10 humans per month it's either
you sell 10 customers per month
or you sell 10 Affiliates per month you
guys see the difference
but only scenario two keeps growing
month after month after month with the
same work
same work more money leverage High isn't
scenario two better
that's a lot more money for the same
work and the best part is it's free you
just attach your offer to their offer
and let them advertise for you so for
example if I owned a massage studio I
might tell six corporations I'll give
all new employees a free massage right
free massage for every employee
now whenever they hire someone new they
send their employees to me AKA free
leads to me every month
and that's all it is anyone can do this
and it's 100 legal
so the affiliate Playbook will show you
how to step one find your ideal
Affiliates step two make them a win-win
offer which is really key if you noted
for this event the win-win is that the
top Affiliates I would provide value to
Their audience rather than saying hey
top Affiliates get a Lamborghini which
would not add value to Their audience
right you can structure way that
everyone wins which is one of my
favorite ways to use Affiliates step
three train them to sell your stuff
because if they don't know how to sell
your stuff they're going to say the
wrong thing and people have bad
expectations step four figure out what
to pay them we paid tens of thousands of
dollars at gym launch for a consultant
to come in who only sets up affiliate
payment compensation programs and I'm
going to give you everything they gave
me
all they do it's all yours
step five get them advertising because
you got them to this point now they got
to get you leads in Step six once they
get you leads you want to keep them
getting you leads so you keep them
advertising
in fact these were the actual sales
numbers from the First full month of
sales from our supplement company
Prestige Labs so you can see there 429
000 that was week one 383 411 404 000
with zero paid ads using 100 affiliates
so if you're trying to add it up it was
1.7 million dollars per month
and the best part was they took care of
the advertising and the selling for us
we just delivered the products
now this was the second time I tried to
launch Affiliates the first time was a
complete disaster and it took me two
years before I launched again and this
time I documented all the mistakes that
I'd made the first time
and since then I've done 75 million
dollars in sales from Affiliates between
our portfolio companies and as a
reminder that this works
today this is the exact process I
followed to get 23 722 Affiliates who
promoted this event
so you could skip every other section
and only get one business to send you
leads using this Playbook and cover the
entire investment for this system for
good
which would transform your entire
business and maybe your life but I value
today only a fraction of my investment
time money at one thousand nine hundred
ninety seven dollars so you'll get lead
magnet Mastery which you can immediately
use to get way more people to want your
stuff that will eventually buy you'll
have the first five client framework so
that anyone can launch the new business
quit the job launch the new product in
whatever division you're in and get the
first customers on board
you'll have the most immediate content
Playbook which we have never shown
publicly everyone tries to look from the
outside in to figure out what we do and
how we do it this will show you step by
step how we've scaled
the cold Outreach Playbook which
literally saved gem launch at its
hardest time and was able to scale a gym
company during covid because that's how
bulletproof it is once you get it right
the paid ads Playbook which has been the
source of my material wealth and is the
fastest way to get new customers even if
you have no reputation
the referral Playbook which is actually
the Silicon Valley hack at getting
unlimited free customers by taking your
customers to get you more customers
and then the affiliate Playbook which is
where you lock arms with other
businesses you find partners and you all
charge forward together and you get to
benefit from their advertising total
value ten two seven nine
so no matter which Playbook you choose
to use
you now have all the Infinity Stones
and if you wanted to use more than one
which I recommend you might be wondering
how do I know which Playbook to use in
what order
which is why I outlined the zero to 100
million dollar scaling roadmap think of
it as The Gauntlet that holds all the
stones
it breaks down the seven levels of
scaling leads in advertising
which will show you exactly what
Playbook to use for your business right
now
and rather than go into detail in each
level
why don't I just show you what it looks
like when you have them all
so instead of wiping out the universe
when you snap your fingers you'll turn
them all into leads
and so this is what it looks like at
scale
your media team scales tons of free
content and all media Types on many
platforms you regularly make offers to
your warm audience to get more customers
or Affiliates your audience Goodwill
makes anything you launch immediately
profitable you have teams running and
scaling profitable paid ads across
multiple platforms your code Outreach
teams get you more customers on
autopilot
you have affiliate managers launching
and integrating all new Affiliates you
have recruiters and recruiting agencies
bringing in more lead Getters your
product is so good that a third of your
customers bringing more customers your
executive team drives all this growth
without you
and you have more engaged leads than you
can possibly handle and that last part
is the most important you have more
engaged leads than you can possibly
handle in other words a 100 million
dollar leads machine
so remember I said earlier a man with an
experience is never a immersive man with
an opinion
the reason I know this is what it looks
like is because I lived it
we cross 10 million a month using the
exact roadmap that I just outlined my
books and courses are my living
documentation of that Journey mind you
took me a while to figure this stuff out
I was stuck for three years between 30
and 40 million a year until a mentor of
mine told me why I was stuck then within
two years we crossed 10 million a month
so for me this road map has cost me a
decade and every mistake that I've made
and if you ignored everything else and
simply got Clarity on what you should be
doing to grow
it would cover the cost of the entire
investment which why I think it's fair
to valued at one thousand seven hundred
ninety seven dollars all right so you're
gonna get lead magnet Mastery you're
gonna get the first five plan framework
you'll get the most immediate content
method to build the brands you want you
can get the cold Outreach Playbook so
that you can get leads in any condition
in any environment you're going to get
the paid ads Playbook that you can crank
with zero reputation to get more
customers you're gonna have the referral
Playbook that can give you the virality
in the business you want that can scale
with the highest margins and you're
going to get the affiliate Playbook
which allow you to partner with other
businesses to get you more leads and the
zero to 100 million dollar scaling
roadmap from someone who's actually been
there
total value 12.76.
this is all the stuff you're going to
get
listen these systems are more valuable
than the masterminds that sell for
twenty five thousand fifty thousand even
a hundred thousand dollars from goobers
who've never even done it
and it will give you hilariously more
value than a hundred thousand dollar
four-year degree
and you've seen
this has produced a hundred million
dollars in sales for me and my companies
and a 46.2 million dollar exit in hard
cost alone this has cost me over 10
million dollars to figure out what
actually works
and if you were to pay me hourly to
teach you one-on-one based on my hourly
earnings or last five years it would
cost you two million dollars
so if I were to price this and what it's
truly worth I wouldn't have any issue
asking you to invest 100 Grand to get
the entire system
and before I tell you the price let me
ask you a question
how much is double your lead flow worth
an extra ten thousand a year
an extra fifty thousand a year an extra
hundred thousand a year extra million
dollars a year
hold that number in your head
really think about it what is that worth
if you knew beyond a shot of a doubt
that it would happen
wouldn't be worth at least that much
because after 100 million dollar offers
Nick tripled his cleaning business from
87 class to 252 clients and Bill took
his Pizzeria from 13 000 a week to
twenty thousand week adding 300 350 000
per year in sales and Aaron went from
shrugging to make his online business
work to netting 1.9 million in eight
months
and natural went from 100 000 a year in
a small Market to 500 000 a year in a
bigger Market an extra 400 000 a year
and Dylan was able to not 2x 3x but 5x
is business you can see in the bottom he
said you've made me more money than I
can ever hope to return thanks for all
you do
Bobby added 1.6 million to his income in
eight months
for all these guys it would have been
worth it at any price
and that's why 100 Elite system is a
bargain at 1276 but consider this
if all this did was give you enough
money to quit your job like it did for
me or allow you to start your first
business like you did for me or save
your business from closing like it did
for me
or if all this it was Triple your leads
like I did for Xavier
or if all this did was in 24 months
because that's how long I've been doing
this give you the skills to launch an
event like this using only what's inside
the system
wouldn't it be worth it
I think so too
which is why it's an even bigger bargain
and not 12076 but four thousand nine
hundred ninety seven dollars because if
every week all it does is get you one
more customer one more referral one more
affiliate it'll pay for itself in months
or even weeks
I mean Ivan didn't even have to finish
my last last book to jump start his
business all right and the best part is
you only invest once but you get to keep
making money using the skills for the
rest of your life
which is why skills are the best
investment look if I put my last
thousand dollars into the S P 500 in
which returns nine percent a year today
I'd only have twenty one hundred and
eighty three dollars
but instead I invested my last thousand
dollars in the SME 500 skills and turned
a thousand dollars into what we have now
so which would you rather have
four thousand nine hundred ninety seven
dollars or your dream
right me too
which is why this may be the best offer
I've ever given at not twelve thousand
not four thousand nine hundred ninety
seven dollars but two thousand nine
hundred ninety seven dollars
but because I want each and every one of
you to 2x 5x 10x your lead flow and your
business over the next 12 months
and I know how life-changing this system
has been for me and my family
and I want this to be affordable for
everyone but still an investment
I'm not going to ask for 1276 even
though be totally reasonable and a
bargain
I'm not going to ask for 4 997 I'm not
even gonna ask for two thousand nine
hundred ninety seven dollars
I'm gonna give you access to everything
we talked about today
for a single payment of
a single payment of
it's free
laughs
I love you guys
[Laughter]
gotcha
yes
it's 100 free
all right it's all yours
that's my way of saying thank you
for being a part of this movement
you guys stoked you guys feeling it you
guys feeling it
you're like what did he forget oh wait
there's more
hahaha
[Laughter]
I see some shell-shock faces
but wait there's more
so on top of that
you'll also get the 100 million leads
audiobook
free
everyone's like Alex makes his money
selling audiobooks it's free
so you get both the 100 million dollar
lead system
and 100 million leads audiobook 100 free
you'll find the system right next to the
100 million offers course on my site you
won't have to opt in it's freely
available for everyone in the public
and you'll get the audiobook it'll be on
my podcast after we're done today all
right so both will be live immediately
after we're done today all right now
oh no we're not we're just believe it or
not we're just getting going so now at
the very beginning I said I was going to
help two types of people today
so I said number one for people who need
to put their oxygen mask on and take
care of themselves and their family I
promise you I will help you get closer
to that today for free period so you're
going to want to wait until the end
because I'm going to deliver on that big
time
and so do you feel like I kept my
promise to group one
great
so now for everybody else this is for
you
for those of you who are in a position
to help me pay it forward
I'm going to show you how it's in your
self-interest to help everyone else
once you see that you'll see you can
accomplish both our missions together
so here's the deal
I wrote 19 drafts of 100 million dollar
leads
I actually found some of my older ones
so my very first version was lead
generation and monetization structures
right wasn't a very good name
I found my V10 one hanging around
and what you guys will get is v19
and I had four four full rewrites
it took me six hours a day for nearly
two years to bring this to you guys in
the cleanest simplest most digestible
way
and every time I didn't want to rewrite
something to make it a little bit
clearer my editor would yell at me you'd
be like there's a 17 year old kid who's
going to sleep with this book under his
pillow to get out of a situation you owe
it to him
and that's what got me through this you
guys
I enjoy writing but it's a hard process
but I stand here now confident
that this is my best work today
so it's with a lot of Pride that I
present to you
the 100 million leads collector's
edition
hardback
but before I tell you where you can grab
your copy
who here's life is made better by the
content the courses and the books
put a money bag in the chat
you can wave too you can you can do both
if you feel like if you're feeling extra
peppy today
you guys glad you showed up you guys
glad you showed up
then you already know if you dropped the
money bag or you're raising your hand
and you've gotten value from the content
the books the courses then you already
know how life transforming skills can be
so help me share them
give a book to two friends
and as a token of my appreciation I'll
give you my hat
so let me tell you why this happened so
much to me
because in the early days
whenever I started a business the first
thing I did was make a hat
it made the little idea ahead of my head
feel real a bit of proof I could hold in
my hands
and many times it felt like the realest
part of my dream
and today this hat is a visual reminder
of my commitment to our new mission
to make real business education
accessible to everyone
and until today there was only one way
you could own this hat and it was by
working at acquisition.com
which is why I wanted this to stay
earned not bought
and I never want to lose that
so if you believe what we believe in
giving first in thinking long in doing
the work that others won't and keeping
your promise in a world that breaks them
and delaying gratification in skills and
education being the ultimate Legacy in
being one of zero
then grab a three pack and give a book
to two friends
change someone's life and pay it forward
and I'll give you my hat as a token of
my appreciation for me you can go to
shop.acquisition.com
and to be clear when you share these
books you will have earned this hat
you can go to shop.acquisition.com
so you can go to that link you can grab
yours now
you can share the books with co-workers
and employees your friend group your
clients For an upcoming event for your
birthday or holiday or because the
Collector's Editions will just be worth
more than any other version of the book
or because it's like the closest thing
doing a Harry Potter release except for
entrepreneurs or having the physical
copy will just be a super status gift
since they're going to be so few of them
in the run out immediately
or because you and your people want to
read at the same time which is how Layla
and I do things
so all I do is I ask you to share them
so now that we've covered that
I've got good news and I've got bad news
the good news is
in six months mosination Grew From Here
to here
now for the bad news
I had to order books here
but I didn't know we'd grow to here
so I only have 150 000 hardbacks
and 30 000 hats on hand
and even though I'm limiting everyone to
a hundred books per order
we will definitely run out very fast
so just to put this in perspective
they're just under 200 000 of you here
right now live
which is already way more than the
amount of hats that I have
and we might have been okay
except on top of that
there's another 500 000 plus people
watching this replay as soon as it
finishes
so you've got two hundred thousand
people live another 500 000 gonna watch
the Replay for a total 500 000 plus
people
and that might have been okay
but on top of that
there's another 1.5 million people
planning to watch this on YouTube
immediately after this is over
for context this is only my YouTube
subscribers and we're going to be
sharing it across all platforms
and this was the last video I posted
which already has 1.5 million views this
is just my last video
and so there's
just under 200 000 of you live 500 000
watching the replay another 1.5 million
heard me watching it on YouTube for a
total of two million people we're gonna
be watching this presentation
and that might have
but on top of that
there's another 23 722 Affiliates who
are going to be sharing this
presentation in this offer and these
hats
with 10 million people Plus on their
email lists the moment this wraps up
and so there's 200 000 of you live
500 000 watts in the replay 1.5 million
are going to be watching this on YouTube
and another 10 million we're gonna get
this today
for a total of 12 million people
who are going to be seeing this
and to be clear
that's how many hats I have
that's how many books we have and this
is how many people will see this
for perspective
this is what it looks like zoomed out
so make sure you get your books for your
homies now like right now
shop.acquisition.com
because they we will we will run out
so here's how you get your books
step one enter this URL in a new browser
or you can hit grab my books on the
dashboard that you had coming into this
event so grab my books will get you
there or you can go shop.acquisition.com
step one
step two click the book pack you want if
you grab a 10 pack you'll also get a hat
all right just FYI
so
grab the pack you want step three
increase the quantity because you want
to share them with your homies you want
to spread the message you want to spread
the good news
step four
click Buy It Now
step five fill out your info
step six select your shipping remember
that books are heavy and governments
require sales tax you can take it up
with your local government all right
just FYI and for those who are
international I'm gonna repeat this
again later because it Bears repeating
if you're International these shipping
rates are insane all right they're nuts
there are more than the cost of the book
it's like buying a book of air ticket to
fly over the ocean to go somewhere all
right so blame travel don't blame me
step seven fill out your payment info
and hit buy now or pay now there we go
so quick delivery expectations we will
ship these in the orders that we receive
them which means the earlier you put
your order in the faster you will get
them
books are heavy heavy so shipping costs
money as a reminder
after you guys finish the hardbacks we
will print the rest as paperbacks which
will take a few weeks but buying right
now today will still be the fastest way
to get them because I want to make sure
that everyone in mosination gets it
the digital stuff will come via email
all right so for all you International
folks right now we're only shipping to
us UK Canada Australia and 28 countries
in the EU and by the way big pain in the
butt to set up
uh again international shipping is
expensive AF they're usually more than
the books
so I repeat this because I know people
have questions and be typing in things I
repeat digital stuff will all come via
the email that you registered for this
event so don't check an email that you
didn't register for this event for so
check the email you registered for this
event for the digital stuff
oh y'all thought I was done
wait did you guys think I was done
okay I'm not done
one more thing
and by the way uh we had to have uh a
team of people coding all through
everything to make sure that we could
have 200 300 000 people the exact second
hit a link so if it takes a second don't
worry it'll smooth out in the next five
or ten minutes not a big deal all right
so you can keep listening if you're
reloading the page not a big one so one
more thing
I have one more promise to deliver on
what about the exclusive bonus for
everyone who came here live and believe
me when I said it would be worth it
what are you guys going to get that
everyone not here isn't is going to
regret not being your life for
well
over the last four years I've been
carefully collecting notes from my last
two books
100 million dollar leads
oops wrong side here we go my magic my
magicians my magicians thing 100 million
dollar leads and 100 million dollar
offers
I've been collecting notes from my last
two years
and I spent countless hours curating
them in a digestible way
so you could see them
see how much work went into these some
of these simple Frameworks like the
value equation like the offer headline
formula you see those Frameworks don't
magically appear
I have to work really hard to turn them
into Frameworks that stand the test of
time
for example this was how many iterations
it took me to come up with the table of
contents the table of contents for this
book 100 million dollar offers all right
so check this out
version one
version two
version three version four version five
version six version seven version eight
version nine if you guys are getting
bored imagine drawing every one of these
little things version 10 version 11
version 12 version 13 version 14 version
15 version 16.
final
and again those little drawings take
some time
if you guys didn't know that I'm the one
who draws the pictures by the way I get
asked like yeah I'm the one who draws
all the pictures in the books
and so as an exclusive bonus
for everyone here today
you're all going to get
a copy
of 100 million dollar Journal
absolutely free
278 pages of Frameworks
which includes all the drawings and
iterations with videos explaining how
each concept came to be and you can see
there the first uh as the first
iteration of the value equation for
those who know what it is
so think of this as the behind the
scenes look or the director's cut of
creating the books and courses all right
this will give you a much deeper
understanding behind the concept so you
internalize them rather than memorizing
them the point is never to memorize the
points to learn and that's why I wanted
to show you the process so that you
could go through it with me and get to
the same conclusion just faster
it'll be sent straight to your inbox
after this is over
and this is I want to be very clear
only for you guys here live today
no one else will get this you guys
decided to show up you guys decided to
take Saturday for my Aussies my new
zealanders who are up at three o'clock
in the morning right now partying here
because you guys want it and believe me
means the world to me I actually can't
even explain how much it means to me it
it's unbelievable
um this is just for you guys here today
and so here's all the free money making
stuff that you guys get just for being
here today number one the 100 million
dollar lead system
number two the 100 million dollar leads
audiobook number three the 100 million
dollar Journal
all free all yours
I told you guys it'd be worth it to stay
until the end until my last breath
and so I have a question for you guys
did I keep my promise to make real
business education accessible for
everyone
let me know in the chat give me a yes or
a thumb or a flame money bags work too
good with money bags
because I gave you everything I have
so
there's a limit of 100 per order we have
only 30 000 hats because I ordered them
a long time ago you go to shop at
shop.acquisition.com get your
collector's three pack share it with a
friend
also
for those who are curious
about what my next book is so you've got
book one 100 million dollar offers
book two 100 million dollar leads
for those who are curious
what my next book is
it's already done
see you guys soon thank you